hey youtubers is charlie is this gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 5 video
we learned so much about Bieber hands
group is busy we look at DC group
episode
I definitely did not expect to get the
big reveal that we got at the end of the
episode
which October talk about during spoilers
I know everyone is still wondering about
Carol to
it looks like next week is when we're
going to learn more about that so all
address that too at the into the video
real quick reminder to turn around a
giveaway starts right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video
real simple so cover for splitting the
absurd if you're not kinda
but here goes during the top five
moments number five the bus lips
it only sets they only made it 15 miles
from the church before the bus
took a dive r.i.p church bus I think the
last reliable car they had was by the
Dodge Charger the prison
so many awesome things revealed in his
brief moment before everything went to
shit
first of Eugene is never going to cut
that here
even if he gets is based punch stop by
Abraham maggie's turley worried about
someone else
it is not bad and we get the start a
more Abraham flashbacks
I didn't expect to get such a deep dive
into his past but
we can learn why he's so crazy number
four
Abraham Eugene origin story so all the
flashbacks just tell the story
up what happened to Abraham before he
met Eugene
is a nice juxtaposition did at the end
the episode he found out
that the thing that saved his life was a
complete lie he was getting ready to
kill himself
so does it matter that Eugene lied to
him I think in the final moments
whenever he was just kneeling down the
road he pry didn't care each is batshit
crazy
it seems like based on the flashbacks
that's what that show was explaining bit
he was just so out of his mind to his
wife and children were free to them
whenever we saw him outside later it
look like their courses that actually
desiccated for a while
even though the time just made it seem
like it was a short amount of time
between him waking up and finding them
gone
I don't think he's gonna die anytime
soon so hopefully we'll get some more
explanation about his life before the
apocalypse
I don't think that his story once he met
Eugene is quite as interesting as
what happened before the apocalypse
though the prospects kinda make it seem
like a terrible person
or at least a well-meaning person who
doesn't realize that is being terrible
you wait group telling me the pressure
pharmacy and buy him some
meds to balance out his role needs to be
slowed
big-time number three rest stop at the
bookstore
is actually the more fun parts the
episode mostly because a pervert Eugene
this is the first time that we've seen
him getting caught watching them have
sex
I would be willing to bet that he's been
doing this the whole time they've been
together as a group
which is a little bit scary but kinda
funny it was nice to finally get some
time with Abraham
and Rosita reading it too much time with
them alone come to find out she is way
smarter than he is
somehow I'm not surprised though Abraham
does not seem like much but thinking man
did you think it was either that they
were burning books to build that fire
and then later we see Eugene reading HG
Wells the book itself
which is the little foreshadowing you
know the shape of things to come just
sending little bit ominous up
what might happen in the near future but
I also like the idea did science fiction
like eugene exists in this fantasy world
where he's like yes
the likely continue I can keep it up
forever turns out not so much
number two Eugene confession number one
I killed the bus
I was little bit upset the tear didn't
go crazier she wants to continue to keep
it a secret
I think maybe because she feels at home
with the group which is starting to feel
comfortable and she doesn't want that to
be destroyed
she seem so much happier in this episode
2 election Eugene rich starting to bind
especially over the mall it on this can
be the French it turned a bit of a
corner
especially the funny but really creepy
moment where she caught him
watching Abraham in Brazil to have sex I
love that she had to stop him from
confessing about the pervert sex stuff
this is
I just came to say thank you you jim has
gotten really interesting lately
mean it's just like he is bursting at
the seams trying to let go the secret to
his
like he just wants to come at him so bad
like you just want to tell someone the
truth
they're still really far away from
Washington DC to know it's not like they
were really close
in my number one WTF moment Eugene
reveals his
big secret secure is total bullshit
there may be a cure out there but he
certainly has no idea what it is
people who read the comics 30 knew about
this but I feel like
even if you didn't the writing was kind
on the wall like he was being very weird
definitely not someone that you should
put your trust in in other Abraham puts
the Sheraton he might be dead
elected because the episode at that
moment that is gonna leave us wondering
weather
now he's still alive in next week we're
jumping back to Caroline Dale so we're
going to wait two weeks at least to find
out
maybe three if we go back to rick in the
group after-care owned a row
so yes Eugene lied there is no cure
everyone's pissed
been going to Washington DC for
absolutely no reason but
that's not technically true they do have
a really good shot a surviving
in Washington DC just because it's so
fortified in this such good
infrastructure
so does it matter that he lied I would
say yes I mean it does matter a little
bit
but he was able to save abraham's life
without really thinking about it
and everyone will have a much better
chance of surviving once they get to DC
that's why I think eventually want
everyone gets over the fact that he's a
total dirtbag for lying to them
they will see the going to DC is a good
thing I think everyone's mostly just
gonna be upset about them having to
split the group up
is was all the people that died along
the way trying to get into DC
let me know what was your favorite
moment and what do you think they're
gonna do now are they gonna head back to
Rick's group are they going to continue
on to DC
remember there is like an ocean I've
walkers in front of them
all say that I think that they're going
to continue on to DC that is gonna find
a different route
overall I give the episode in a minus
for giving us that deep psychological
dived into Abraham
is really was his episode even though
Eugene had the big reveal
Michael cutlets the actor that plays
abraham was actually doing a Twitter
cuny before the episode in
doing a whole bunch interviews just
explaining how damaged Abraham is
psychologically I mean he was damaged in
the flashbacks so think about where he
is now
is whether the walking dead so much is
that it tells the Jinnah motional story
for these characters like it's not all
about the gore
adjust them just killing a buncha
walkers like it's not the spectacle
it really gets into the emotional
collateral damage during an interview
Michael collects explain that
they let these little bit more vague
about what happened to his family in the
flashbacks
it is a little bit more graphic winds up
happening to them before they die
but the effect is still the same one
Abraham it is explains why he is so
crazy in the head and how he uses
Eugene's mission to get over it
art at least ignore it
I think Abraham and present day now is
going to be just like Rick was
after the mid-season finale last year
just almost catatonic
the keys broken emotionally Eni's a
little bit broken physically too
the difference is that you just saw it
on Rackspace just little more plainly
like his base was literally smashed in
but that
pretty much what happened to Abraham
emotionally just in general the Abraham
my favorite performer the episode Rosina
number two though
she is a smart I can't wait to see more
scenes with her just one upping other
characters
I feel like this is a subtle way to the
fact that she's not just a pretty face
so like I said next week some really
exciting said to look for to Lhasa Carol
lot today also be sure to subscribe to
my video
looks like what's going to be happening
is we're going to rewind to before
Carroll ended up in the hospital
based on a teaser footage it looks like
they definitely had a planned
so part of her being in there is on
purpose I'm also got my fingers crossed
that they're going to explain
who it is with their own the bushes
which i think is no up in just addressed
the issue have Eugene being dead or
alive
I think that he still live I think
Abraham is going to have to live with
him
walking around alive for a little while
longer no idea when he'll actually end
up dying though
but both he and Michael coloreds were up
to series regulars the season
if that means anything on Walking Dead
anymore I guess the chemical off at any
time
just like normal be posting a Q&A for
this tomorrow you can click here to get
a login stations are posted
and you can click here for my episode
for video thank you so much watching
with of hyper and I will see gas
tomorrow